[Music]
hallo YouTube just love us and my
friends this is grunge in here welcome
to my 37 episode of chest strap series
in this episode I'm going to show you a
wonderful high profile trap and in fact
a mini wrap rota against Phil adore
Larsen variation from the white
perspective the opening arises after the
following model evil ePHI Knight to f3
d6 d4 and now by far the main line move
here is he captures d4 and after Knight
captures d4 black first attacked this
efore pawn with Knight to f6 and after
Knight to c3 defending Black has two
choices once again the main line here is
Bishop to e7 but the black bishop
remained passive on the e7 square so
other good option for the black is to
play g6 and fianchetto that bishop well
this is known as Larson variation and in
the last decade this move was very
popular until white come up with this
fantastic Bishop to g5 idea and after
that this variation completely vanished
now our main trap occurs when black
respond with ethics however before we
look at it the most important point I
like to highlight here that if your
opponent continued with Bishop to g7
which is the obvious choice after that
white plan of campaign remains so easy
Queen to d2 and as you can see I have
highlighted over here the attacking
scheme of castling on the Queen side
with Bishop 2 at 6 is too much for the
black camp
for example if black castles at this
point then after we Castle black can't
play at six
that means this night will remain pin he
can't play c5
the obvious reason is after night to b5
the d6 pawn is a goner and apart from
alders the simplest and the easiest plan
for the white camp is to continue with
h4 h5 and get he'll lose quickly on the
black King side which is altogether very
difficult for the black camp well same
goes if black delayed the castle and
continued with the move at six as after
the small white can simply respond with
Bishop to f4 and now in order to Castle
black has to play either the Muji fire
on night to h5 and in both the cases it
is white who get benefit out of it and
again
this positions are hugely favoring the
white camp as per the database so in
short to cut the long story short after
Bishop to g5 it is only white who get
fun in all of this variation well apart
from all this the cherry on the top is
there is a nasty trap exists if black
continued it at 6 which in fact as per
the online database played in more than
20 games and the highest elo trapped is
more than 2,300 rated opponent I am
sorry to say but the 6 to move at 6 is a
big-time disaster for black and after
this by force white is winning in all
the variations now before I show it to
you if you want to give a try just pause
the video and try to find out the
sequence where white obtained are
completely winning advantage
okay are you ready let's get started the
first move is very obvious Bishop
captures f6 Queen captures up six now
white attack the Queen as well as the
juicy c7 square so black response is
again forced he has to play Queen to d8
now another attack on c7
wait Knight to be fire and yet another
only defense exist namely Knight to g6
so so far you can see every single move
is first but after White's next reply
black can see his death nil as Queen to
d4 and black is completely busted
well there is an important threat of
capturing the rook in the corner and the
poor thing about this rookies it cannot
move as after Knight to f6 Jack King to
e7 and Knight captures g8 just within
the 12th move of the game white obtained
the whole rogue so that means black has
the only defense left here namely AB 6
but after this the real fun start with
Knight captures f6 check if the King
moves flurry 7 square then after Knight
to d5
White will get the rook in the corner so
obviously black has to play the only
moon King to f7 attacking the knight but
just one move and black can pack his
back and go home did you spot it yup
this dazzling Knight sacrifice with
Knight wedge 5 well obviously if black
take this 9 then we are going to grab
the rook in the corner and not only in
that condition white get the exchange
but black king is clearly misplaced so
accordingly
as I have highlighted over here black
has three choices number one which is
obviously very bad if your parents
continue with King to g8 which in fact
happened in one of my lower rated game
well after that there's a force made
guys can you spot it yup it's very easy
Queen check Bishop to e6 Queen captures
c6 Jack King two at 7:00 and after Queen
to f7 check Bishop to g7 black King has
been kissed to the deaths just within
the opening stage the second option rook
to g8 is also very bad as after Bishop
to c4 check it is clear that white is
getting the exchange anyways after the
forcing line Bishop to e6
Bishop captures e6 King captures e6 and
now Queen to defy and that rukon g8 left
the board very soon last but not least
what happens if black plays the most
critical response namely rook to at 7
where after that once again white will
deliver this bishop check and after
Bishop to e6 here you can take this
bishop but I like Knight to a4 move
battle and as per the engine Bishop
captures c4 is the only response left
for the black if black continue 8 night
to c5 then Knight captures c6 is a very
strong reply as the knight on e6 will
remain in the pin so obviously let's see
what happens after Bishop captures c4
and I think this is the only line where
white will not get an exchange but he
get the supreme advantage again
poorly placed black ink here black has
to already be careful as king to e8 is
the only response if he continue with
other moves then he's fine himself in a
use trouble for example King to g7 leads
to Knight to e6 check and the black
queen is a goner so that's not a
possible if King to e7 then this is
probably the easiest one yup
Queen to b6 a lovely picture as
checkmate on the board and the third
option King to f6 is again very bad due
to the following white move Queen to g8
we are tacking to sport and the natural
response rook to g7 is completely out of
the equation has now the King dance of
black king will commence with Quint we
six check King to g5 h 4 check King
takes F 4 and after g3 King f3 and night
to d4 we invite this black ink finally
to the g2 Square where we can give this
lovely death kiss finally what happens
if King goes to the eh square well here
my recommendation is you should simply
castle on the Queen side and as I have
mentioned earlier this is the only
variation where yes you only get a pawn
after the whole trap completed but look
at the pathetic position of black not
only his King cannot castle and stuck in
the center but he can never play c6 and
on top of everything we have Queen to e6
check coming up and all together if you
check this position with any strong
engine it will tell you that white has
are completely winning advantage from
this position
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this amazing trapping line in the
Philadelphia region remember once you
open and play the move at six deliver
this forcing sequence Bishop captures AB
six Queen captures f6 Knight to d5 Queen
to d8 Knight to be file twice attacking
on c7 and after Knight 2 is 6 and the
move Queen to d4 by fours
white attained the winning position just
within tenth move of the game thank you
for watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and I'll meet you in my next episode
very soon bye and take care